[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
2016 من طرف ثالث وروسيا تستعد لرد صاروخ
جديد
بقبول استقاله الحكومه الكويتيه رئيسا
وزراء بعد اقل من اربعه اشهر على تشكيله
رابعه تستعرض واقع النقل العام في شرق
السعوديه
230,000 راكب منذ اكتوبر الماضي
في الرابعه ايضا
بعد موجه امطار غزيره محميه الملك عبد
العزيز ترتدي اللون الاخضر وجوله حصريه
للرابعه
وترقب الى نصف نهائي السوبر السعودي
الهلال في مواجهه الفيحاء
وكريستيانو رونالدو يقود النصر امام
الاتحاد
الصعيد في اوكرانيا الله يهدؤوا فبعد
القرار الامريكي الالماني بتزويد كيا
بالدبابات كشفت صحيفه
عن وجود محادثات حول ارسال الطائرات اف 16
الى اوكرانيا طرحتها شركه لوكيد مارتن
المصنعه للطائره
مسؤولون في شركه صرح انه في ظل توجه الغرب
لتقديم المزيد من الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا
فانها ستزيد انتاجها من طائره اف 16 حيث
ان بعض الدول ستعيد تصدير طائره الامريكيه
لكيف لحمايه مجالها الجوي ولم تنخرط شركه
المصنعه في المحادثات مباشره لكن البيت
الابيض ما زال على الموقف الرافضي لتزويد
اوكرانيا بالمقاتله اف 16 مشاهده على انه
يجب الحصول على موافقه الحكومه الامريكيه
في حال بيع او نقل مقاتلات امريكيه الى
دوله ذلك
وفي اول رد فعل بعد اعلان
غربيه تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات قال
المتحدث
واشنطن والدول الغربيه على انه تورط مباشر
في الصراع باوكرانيا واضاف الكرم بان
روسيا لا تفكر بتغيير وضع العمليات الخاصه
في اوكرانيا
اكد وزير الدفاع الالماني
سيتم ارسالها الى اوكرانيا في نهايه شهر
مارس
في نهايه الربع الاول من العام لقد قلت في
نهايه شهر مارس على ما اعتقد كل ما اعرفه
هو ان هذا هو الوقت المناسب
ومن جانبه على وزير الدفاع البولندي
ماريوس كلاش في مقابله اذاعيه ان الجيش
البولندي سيستلم اولا 58 دبابه امريكيه من
طرازي ابرامز في هذا العامه واوضح بان اول
الدفعه من هذه الدبابات ستصل بولندا في
الربيع القادم مشيرا الى انها ستكون من
الطراز الاقدم والمستعمله وستعوض الخسائر
جراء تسليم دبابات تي اثنين وسبعين
القديمه الى اوكرانيا
قال مسؤولون في كيا بنا الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه يسقطت اكثر من 15 صاروخا روسيا
وطلقت باتجاه العاصمه خلال احداث جوله من
الضربات الجويه التي تشونها موسكو وقال
رئيس اداره العسكريه ان الجيش الاوكراني
يواصل عمله ويتصدى للضربات الروسيه في
اشاره الى ان اخطر او خطر الغارات الجويه
لم ينتهي بها
حتى رئيس بلديه العاصمه الاوكرانيه بس كان
على البقاء في الملاج صباح الخميس بعد
سقوط بقايا صاروخ في ضاحيه بالعاصمه ما
ادى الى وقوع قتيل وجريحين
في الكويت اصدار امير البلاد الشيخ نواف
الاحمد الجابر الصباح امرا اميريا بقبول
استقاله الحكومه التي يراسوها الشيخ احمد
النواف بعد ثلاثه اشهر فقط من تشكيلها
وذلك اثر خلاف مع مجلس الامه بشان الاتفاق
على مطالب شعبيه يرغب النواب في دفع
الحكومه
بعد اصرار الحكومه على موقفها بشان اعاده
تقارير اللجنه الماليه الى اللجان من دون
اي تعهدت
من الكويت تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه شهد
المتروك شاهد مرحبا بك مدى بعد تقديم او
موافقه امير البلاد على استقاله الحكومه
الكويتيه ما الخيارات او الاجراءات
طبعا هذه تعتبر ثاني استقاله ليه حكومه
رئيس الوزراء الشيخ احمد النواف التي
تشكلت في اكتوبر الماضي بعد هذه الاستقاله
طبعا سيكون هناك مجال همم امير البلاد
لتكليف اا رئيس وزراء جديد وبالتالي بعد
تكليف رئيس الوزراء الجديد لا نعلم حتى
هذه اللحظه سيكون هو نفسه همم الشيخ احمد
النواف او همم يعني رئيس وزراء جديد هو من
سيتم تكلفه
لتشكيل حكومه جديده طبعا تشكيل الحكومه
الجديده سيكون من اختصاص رئيس الوزراء
المقبل همم يتم تشكيلها وتسليم هم او
تكليف الوزراء الجديد عده حقائب وزاريه
همم خالد طبعا هذه الحكومه التي يتراسها
او المستقله التي يتراسها الشيخ احمد
النواف كان من ضمنهم همم بين همم يعني تم
اختيارهم قبل الشعب وبالتالي تحويلهم الى
وزراء كانت هناك طبعا يعني اختلاف في
وجهات النظر همم من حيث يعني عقد الجلسات
في مجلس الامه همم طبعا في السابق كان بعض
النواب يقولون بان كيف يتم رفع جلسات مجلس
الامه رغم اكتمال النصاب بحضور همم النواب
مع غياب الحكومه اليوم نرى بعض النواب
تردد في همم يعني همم في همم هذا الشيء
ولم يذكره رغم اكتمال اني صعب يعني في
اختلاف في اراء لبعض النواب مع هذه
الحكومه الجديد او المستقيله
طيب شكرا جزيلا لكي يشاهد المتروك مراسله
العربيه من الكويت
اذا كان ولي العهد الكويت الشيخ مشعل
الاحمد قال في كلمه الله في ال 22 من
يونيو لعمل الماضي ان المشهد السياسي في
الكويت تمزقه الاختلافات والصراعات
والمصالح الشخصيه
والتحديات
والاخطار المحيطه بنا مع الاسف الشديد
بعيده عن الطموح ولا تحقق المقاصد الشعبيه
الماموله والمنتظره فما زال المشهد
السياسي
تمزقه الاختلافات
وتدمره الصراعات
وتسعيره المصالحه والاهواء الشخصيه على
حساب استقرار الوطن وتقدمه
وازدهاره ورفاهيه شعبه
كما قالولي عهد الكويت الشيخ مشعل لاحمد
انه في حاله عوده الازمه التي مرت بها
الكويت من صراع بين السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه بانه سيتم اتخاذ اجراءات قويه
مصلحه الكويت وشعبها فوق كل اعتبار
ونناشدكم ابناء وطننا العزيزي
الا تضيعوا فرصه تصحيح مسار المشاركه
الوطنيه حتى لا نعود الى ما كنا عليه لان
هذه العوده لن تكون في صالح الوطن
والمواطنين وسيكون لنا في حاله عودتها
اجراءات اخرى ثقيله الواقع والحدث
محمد السبتي سيد محمد حياك الله معك
هذه الحكومه الاربعين تقريبا وصحح لي يعني
في الرقم على مدى تاريخ الكويت
يمكن عدد الحكومات التي استكملت مدتها
القانونيه همم سيد محمد اذا كنت تسمعني لم
يتجاوز عدد الاصابع الواحد الان امير
الكويت حذر من انه في حاله عوده الازمه
الى الحاله التي شيدتها الكويت خلال عقود
فسيتم اتخاذ اجراءات قويه هل سيتم بالفعل
الان تغير هذا الموقف هذه الحاله حسب ما
حذر وحدد ايضا ولي العهد الكويتي في كلمه
الى خير
سيد محمد
طيب يبدو
طيب قبل الذهاب الى ضيفي من الكويت نتوقف
مع هذه
مع هذا العرض حول الحكومات الكويتيه خلال
سته اشهر
[موسيقى]
ضيف من الكويت الصحفي محمد السيد محمد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه الان تعود
الكويت الى المربع الاول في المشهد
السياسي في حاله الصراع بين السلطتين
التشريعيه والتنفيذيه وهي الحاله التي
كانت عليها الكويت خلال عقود ماضيه طويله
لكن هل الوضع الان او المعالجه ستختلف كما
قال وحذر ولي العهد الكويتي في خطابه
الاخير بان بانه سيتم اتخاذ اجراءات قويه
هذا هو المامول المامول ان نقتنع جميعا
باننا نمارس عمليه خاطئه
المامول ان تقتنع جميع التيارات السياسيه
الفاعله في الكويت ان ما نمارسه من 60 سنه
ليست ديمقراطيه هي عمليه انتخابيه ليست
مكتمله الدائره الكهربائيه لا يمكن بحال
ان تنتج الا عن طريق الصدفه نحن مارسناها
مرارا كثيره منذ 60 سنه ولم يعني تنتج اي
شيء الا بطريق الصدفه ما لم يقتنع جميع
التيارات السياسيه بهذه الحقيقه الواضحه
جدا للعيان فلن يتغير شيء لكن المامون من
الحكومه ومن القياده تتخذ يعني قرارا
حاسما ينقذ البلاد من هذه المتاهه التي
نعيشها اجيانا بعد اجيال ثم لا نجد اي
بصيص انا همم من خلال هذه العمليه
لقد تماما
اليوم نفس الحاله تتكرر
نفس التجربه نفس الازمه نفس الادوات نفس
المكونات تتغير الاشخاص
ويتم تكرارها
ويتم كما قلت ربما ترقب لنتيجه يعني مع
انه المنطق السياسي بيقول بانه اذا كانت
المعادله بهذا الشكل فلا يمكن توقع اي
نتيجه فبالتالي او اين نتيجه مختلفه
فبالتالي ما طبيعه الاجراءات التي يجب
اتخاذها اليوم دون اي تاخير
الاجراءات التي يجب اتخاذها هو همم هي ما
هو مقتنع به جميع افراد الشعب وحيد الفاضل
للمشاهده الكريم جميع افراد الشعب الكويتي
بما فيهم الحكومه مقتنعون ان هذه العمليه
تحتاج الى تعديل تعديل في الدستور تعديل
في الاليه لكن لا احد يجروا على هذا
التعديل لا احد يجروا على هذا التعديل لان
كل المقتنعون بالتعديل كلهم يرى التعديل
من زاويه فهم يعتقدون انهم في حال فتح باب
التعديل سوف يلجاون الى نصف هذا الدستور
ثم الاتيام الدستور اخر لهذه الخطوره يعني
يعجز الكل عن مصارعه نفسه بالحقيقه نحن في
مازق حقيقي نحن المازق الحقيقي اننا نمارس
فعلا سياسيا بحال لا ياتي بالنتيجه اي ان
كانت المشكله ليست في الحكومه وليست في
النواب وليست في طافت الدستوريه وليست في
مشاريع القوانين التي تطرح ليست هذه
المشكله هذه بعض ظواهر المشاكل التي
نعانيه من 60 سنه الاشكاليه الحقيقه
الحقيقيه في هذا النظام وهذا النظام متفق
على وجوب تغييره لكن لا احد يجرى على
تغييره همم ما لم يعني نص دم بهذه الحقيقه
نظم انفسنا ونظم الشارع الكويتي وتنصدم
التيارات السياسيه وتاخذ عصا السبق في
تغيير هذه الاليه فاننا سوف ندور في ذات
الحلقه المفرغه التي شاهدناها باعمارنا
وسوف يشاهدها في الازمه الاخيره لان لم
يكن بالامكان افضل مما كان يعني هناك من
يقول بانه من من من من الحق الدستوري
للنوا في البرلمان يقدم جواب للحكومه
بالتالي لماذا دائما تكرر الحكومه كما
يقولون نفس المشكله نفس الطريقه في
التعاطي لماذا لا تذهب الى المواجهه مثلا
داخل او تحت قبه البرلمان خلال
من خلال رسوم من خلال احصائيات من خلال
ارقام تعالج المشكله او تعالج جزء منها
كمنطقه للالتقاء بين الاطراف في هذه
الحاله يعني
لست دافع عن الحكومه لكن حقيقه الامر ان
الاستجوابات تستخدم استخداما خاطئا
الاستجوابات سلاح تستخدم بطريقه خاطئه
بمعنى هذا الكلام ما تفضلت به هو حقيقه
الامر يجب على الحكومه ان تواجه تلك
الاستجوابات وانت تفندها امام الشعب ثم
تنتهي هذه الاستجوابات ان كانت ان كان
الوزير على موقف حق لكن الحكومه تعلم انه
اذا اراد ال 50 استقصادها باستجوابات
فانها ما تنتهي من استجواب حتى تدخل في
استجواب وقد مارست هذا بعض الكتله
السياسيه في البرلمانات السابقه ينتهي
الاستجواب الساعه الثانيه عشره ظهرا
الساعه 1:00 ظهرا تتقدم استجوابات وزراء
اخرين ثم تدور العجل الحكومه تعي ان
استجوابات المقدمه ليست انا لا اطعن
بالنواب لكن ليست بهدف محاسبه هذا الوزير
او ذاك الوزير عن بعض الاعمال هي نزاع
راسي ان انتهى هذا الاستجواب فسوف
يفتح الباب لسيل من الاستجوابات ضد
الوزراء او ضد رئيس الوزراء الحكومه تعي
هذا ويعيش الشعب ايضا وقد مارسدت كثير من
الكتل السياسيه لذلك همم رثاءه الحكومه ان
تقديم الاستجوابات في هذه المرحله يعني لم
يمضي على تشكيل الحكومه وعلى تسلم هؤلاء
الوزراء الا بضعه اشهر ثم تقدم ضدهم
استجوابات همم في ظني ان الحكومه ترى ان
مثل هذا التصرف هو استخدام سيء لتلك
الاسلحه الدستوريه وانه سوف تستخدم تلك
الكتل هذه الاسلحه همم بالسوء ذاته متى
انتهت هذه الاستجرام اذا كان الحل هذا كما
تقول ويعرفه الجميع الكويتيين يعني سواء
كان على مستوى الحكومه او على مستوى
النواب
الكل يعرف انه هناك ثغرات يتم استغلالها
في هذه التجربه في الدستور الكويتي ربما
في العلاقه بين السلطتين ويجب سد هذه
الثغرات
ومعالجتها همم
من هو الرجل الذي اا يمكن يعني ان يحل هذه
المشكله اليوم ولماذا لا يواجهها بالفعل
لماذا لا تطرح هذه النقطه ويتم معالجه هذه
الامر بدلا من تعطيل مصالح المواطنين
والبلد
وجعلها تقف في خانه معينه في مقابل يعني
تقدم ونمو واقتصاد ورخاء ربما كما يرى
البعض في المحيط الاقليم
نحن امام خيارين الخيار الاول ان يتم
تعديل الدستور والدستور لا يتم تعديل الا
بموافقه ثلثي اعضاء مجلس الامه
والموافقه الاميريه الموافقه مشترطه
باجتماع
هاتين الفئتين سموه الامير والثلثي اعضاء
مجلس الامه ومتى ما فتحنا يعني باب تعديل
الدستور فسوف يعني تتشرد مواد الدستور
كلها لان
الاسلاميون يرون وجوب تعديله في بعض
المناحي ويريدون اصوات غيرهم اللي يساريون
يريدون تعديله في مناحي اخرى همم
الاسلاميون الشيعه وغير ذلك فهذا الخيار
للاسف لا احد يتحمل المسؤوليه لاننا نمارس
وهذه العمليه لمصالح يعني حزبيه في قويه
عائليه سميها انا قلت اكثر من مره
الديمقراطيه التي فارسها لا تنتج ابدا
يعني رجال دوله هي تنتج دوله رجال وهذا ما
نوعاني
الحل الاخر المطروح ان تتجه السلطه الى
الغاء هذا الدستور وهو حل غير دستوري
الدستور لا يبيح لها الغاء هذا الدستور
لكنه يعني انتهجت السلطه مثل هذا النهج في
اكثر من سنه في ال في 86 في 76 مثلا يعني
اوقفت العمل
بمواد بعض الدستور وهو ما تعارف عليه
الكويتيون بالحل غير الدستوري وكيله
الحلين مرهين لكنه يعني للاسف اقول لها
وانا كويتي يقولها بمراره لا احد ينهض
بهذا الحل المر لمواجهه تلك المشاكل التي
نعانيها اجيا ليس تستمر الكويت في هذه
الدواء في هذه الحاله من الفوضى والعباسيه
السياسيه لكن السؤال هنا اذا كان الامر
سيستمر بهذا الشكل
الناس ليش تتعطل مصالحهم
ليش تتوقف المناقصات ليش تتوقف المشاريع
القرارات هل هناك في الدستور ما ينص على
توقف هذا العمل العمل الحكومي يعني ليش ما
يكون في عمل حكومي على الاقل بغض النظر عن
المدير وزير موظف او اي شخص
تتوقف لان هذه العمليه البائده التي
اسميناها زورا وبهتانا ديمقراطيه ربطت كل
الامور في بعضها اصبحت اصبح الوزير مرتبط
بموافقه بعض النواب لانه ما لم يسترضها
هؤلاء لانه فسوف يفتحون عليه ابواب جهنم
انتقادا واستجوابات واسئله برلمانيه
النائب مضطر كذلك
لموافقه بعض الوزراء ولموافقه بعض
القواعد الانتخابيه حتى يستمر كذلك يعني
تكوين ثروات الكل يعلم ان مجلس الامه كما
يقول كثير من الناس هو افضل مشروع تجاري
لاي شخص يدخل الانسان لا يملك شيء والواقع
يقول انه يخرج منه يملك ما يمكن يملكه اي
تاجر المساله مرتبطه ببعض نعم تتوقف جميع
المصالح لانه لا احد ياخذ بسده
الكل خائف من الكل للاسف اشكرك شكرا جزيل
من الكويت صحفي المحامي محمد السبت شكرا
جزيلا
في الرابعه بعد قليل احباطون محاوله تهريب
ثلاثه ملايين حبه كبتاجون في بناء الملك
عبد العزيز في شرق السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق مايك بومبيو في مذكراته
التي كتبها تحت عنوان لا تعطي اي بوصه
القتال من اجل امريكا التي احب قاله انه
ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان
رجل اصلي
وسيثبت انه احد اهم قاده عصريه وشخصيه
تاريخيه بحق على المسرح العالمي وصف بومبي
وعلاقته الدبلوماسيه مع المملكه بانها
كانت
تغيض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه مؤكدا بان
العلاقه الامنيه بين الولايات المتحده
والسعوديه مهمه للغايه
دراسه المشروع ربطه سكاكين بين مدينه حفر
الباطن السعوديه والبصره في العراق قدم
كشفه امين محافظه حفر الباطن خلف العتيبي
خلال اليوم الختامي لمنتدى فرص في العاصمه
السعوديه
الرياضيه
[موسيقى]
اعماله بعد ثلاثه ايام شهد التوقيع عدد من
الاتفاقيات ومذكرات التفاهم بالاضافه الى
التسويق 5000 فرصه استثماريه في مختلف في
مناطق السعوديه
من ملتقى فرص في الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن
مرحبا بك معي حصيله ثلاثه ايام من فعاليات
واعمال هذا الموسم
الى ساعاته الاخيره قبل الاختتام بعد
ثلاثه ايام شهيده حضور اعداد كبيره جدا من
الخبراء والوزراء والمختصين والاملاء على
مستوى مناطق السعوديه وعلى مستوى حتى خارج
السعوديه كان هنالك جلسه لامين همم عمان
وكذلك امين المنامه وكذلك امين الرياض وكل
امناء ومناطق السعوديه التي تحدث فيها عن
عدد كبير من الفرص الاستثماريه وايضا عن
اداره المدينه وكيفيه تطويرها ورفع جوده
الحياه والمساهمه في تحسين المشهد الحضري
كل هذه همم مواضيع كانت مطروحه على طاوله
الجلسات الرئيسيه بالاضافه الى تسهيل
عمليه الاستثمار ورحله المستثمر وهذا ما
تحدث به وزير الشؤون البلديه والقرويه
والاسكان امس عندما قال بان هذا المنتدى
او الملتقى في سيرته الثانيه استطاع من
خلاله ان يحسن عمليات الاستثمار او رحله
المستثمر بشكل اكبر كان هنالك العديد من
الاعلانات اللافته التي هي همم في مختلف
مناطق السعوديه نتحدث عن اكبر مشروع او
صفقه استثماريه في القطاع الاعلاني تم
الاعلان عنها ام يوم الامس من امين الرياض
في همم المنطقه وفي مدينه الرياض ايضا كان
هنالك حديث من امين المنطقه الشرقيه عن
مشروع
للنقل البحري تم همم طرحه في الملتقى
البحث عن مستثمرين وهذا المشروع يربط كافه
مدن المنطقه الشرقيه المطله على البحر
نتحدث عن الخبر والدمام وكذلك القطيف
والجبير وراس تنوره
ببعضها البعض عبر النقل البحري بالاضافه
الى دراسه او خطط مستقبليه لربطه ب همم
دول الخليج الخليفه سواء كان البحرين او
قطر او همم كل دول الخليج على البحر اا
العربي البحر الخليج العربي اذا هنالك
الكثير من الصفقات التي تم الاعلان عنها
والاعلانات قبل قليل همم تم الاعلان بتاعه
وتحدث مع شركه سفن الماء لك او المملوكه
لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه والعامله في
قطاع الترفيه عن انهم اطلقوا او قالوا
بانهم اطلقوا همم عدد من المشاريع في تبوك
تحديدا مشروع ترفيهي ضخم وهم لديهم
ميزانيه تقدر ب 50 مليار ريال يبحثون من
خلال هذا الملتقى على عقد الصفقات وابراب
الاتفاقيات بين بعضهم البعض بالاضافه الى
همم التوسع في مناطق الرياض
مختلفه هذا كل ما حدث خلال هذه الثلاثه
ايام والعنوان الابرز لهذا الملتقى تسير
رحله المستثمر وتحسين المشهد الحضري
واداره المدن واستقلالها اقتصاديه لتصرف
على نفسها من خلال مواردها المختلفه شكرا
حقق مشروع النقل العام للحفلات في المنطقه
الشرقيه خلال الاشهر القليله ارقام كبيره
في عدد ركاب بحسب ما اعلنته امانه المنطقه
الشرقيه بلغ عدد الركاب اكثر من 20000 شخص
منذ منتصف اكتوبر الماضي
لتوسيع المسارات الحافلات وتجهيز المحطات
على اعلى مستوى عبد الرحمن
نقله كبيره يشهدها مشروع النقل العام
بالحفلات في منطقه الشرقيه بعد انطلاقه
قبل اشهر قليله لنتعرف على ابرز ملامحه
[موسيقى]
هذا المشروع يشمل ثمانيه مسارات هذه
المسارات تربط مراكز النمو ونقاط الجذب في
القطيف و الدمام
عدد الحفلات يصلوا الى 77 حافله كل حافله
يبلغ عدد مقاعدها 35 مقعدا هذه الحافلات
تتقاطر على جميع الخطوط بمده زمنيه تتراوح
ما بين 15 الى 33 دقيقه اخر احصائيات تقول
ان اعداد الركاب منذ بدايه تشغيل التجريبي
في اكتوبر الماضي حتى قبل ايام قليله وصل
الى اكثر من 20030 الفرح
يستطيع المواطن والمقيم في المنطقه
الشرقيه حجزا تذكرته لركوب هذه الحافلات
عبر تطبيق ذكي للهواتف المحموله يستطيع من
خلاله المستفيد حجز تذاكر ومعرفه مسارات
الحافلات وكذلك اقرب حافله لموقع مستثمر
امانه المنطقه الشرقيه بدورها اكدت ان
تطوير قطاع النقل العام بالحافلات هدفون
استراتيجيون للامانه حيث سيساهم في سهوله
الانتقال داخل المدن خاصه لغير القادرين
على تملك او قياده المركبات الخاصه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي من منطقه الشرقيه العربيه
ونبقى في الدمام حيث تمكنت الجمارك
السعوديه من احباط محاوله تهريب نحو ثلاثه
ملايين حبه كبتاجون من ارساليه مخبا داخل
تجويف الواح الخشبيه في ميناء الملك عبد
العزيز في الدمام شرقيه البلاد
[موسيقى]
رابع بعد قليل
بعد موجه امطار غزيره محميه الملك عبد
العزيز ترتدي اللون الاخضر وجوله حصريه
للرابعه
صحيفه امريكيه تكشف عن محادثات لتزويد كيف
بطائرات اف 16 من طرف ثالث وروسيا تستعد
لرد صاروخ جديد
امر النمر بقبول استقاله الحكومه الكويتيه
رئيسا ووزراء بعد اقل من اربعه اشهر على
تشكيلها
رابعه تستعرض واقع النقل العام في شركه
السعوديه
بعد موجه امطار غزيره محميه الملك عبد
العزيز ترتدي اللون الاخضر وجوله حصريه
للرابعه
وتركبون لنصف نهائي السوبر السعودي الهلال
يواجه الفيحاء
وكريستيانو رونالدو يقود النصر امام
الاتحاد
المطبق على تعز بشكل كبير على مرضى الكلى
خاصه اولئك الذين يخضعون لجلسات الغسيل
الكلوي كلها داخل المدينه
من مناطق سيطره الميليشيات الى سلوكي طرق
جبليه وبمسافه تصل الى اكثر من خمس ساعات
الوصول الى مراكز الغسيل بعد اغلاق
الميليشيات المنافذه الرئيسيه امامهم في
شرق المدينه
خمس ساعات على المركبات يقطعها عبر طرق
الجبليه وعره للوصول الى مركز الغسيل وسط
المدينه على هذا الحال اذا يتجرع سعيد
الشرعبي قسوه السفر اسبوعيا كغيره من مرضى
الفشل الكلوي الذي ضاعت الحصار الحوثي
معاناتهم وغيب البعض عن الموعد المحدد
لجلسات الغسيل في المركز هذا
مواصلات حسب المواصلات يعني الان بطريق
يعني تكاليفها اكثر من ازياء ازيد من كل
مره ازيد من اول
يومين بدون غسيل حتى الذي يموت يموت والذي
يطلع له يعني يسموه بيزيد السموم اللي
يزيد ما يشرب همم يموت ما هذا يعني ما
علاجنا الا غسيل فقط لو كان علاقنا في
الصيدليه نشتري علوم ولكن لقينا غسيل فقط
اكثر من 450 مصابا بالفشل الكلوي في تعز
تهدد الحرب والحصار الحوت حياتهما الى
جانبهم لساعات في نقاط التفتيش التابعه
للمليشيات تمنع تلك النقاط الحوتيه ايضا
دخول محاليل الغسيل الكلوي والادويه
الخاصه بهم الى المدينه ما يهددو باغلاق
المراكز ابوابها امام المرضى
انه راعي الهامه يجيبوا لنا دايسه ما كنت
تعبان ما ما اعرف كهرباء ما نقدرش عاد
ناكل ولا نمشي ولا نرقد ما معنا الا هو
هذا الغسيل
الشكر والتقدير المركز الملك سلمان لغات
الانسانيه الذي قام برفض مركز الفشل
الكلوي مستشفى الثوره تعز في 2500 جلسه
غسيل الكلاكي دفعه اولى من المرحله
الثانيه وهذا يشكل الاهميه كبيره لمرضى
الفشل الكلوي حيث لدينا همم حالات كثيره
نستقبل في اليوم الواحد من ثمانيه الى 88
مريض فشلوي
مركز غسيل الكلى في مستشفى الثوره بتعز
تسلمت وزاره الصحه من مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه قبل ايام اكثر
من سته و 30 من الادويه ومحاليل غسيل
الكلى لتخفيف من معاناه مرضى الكلى ال
سعيد العربي
تعز
رصدت كاميرا العربيه اتساع المسطحات
الخضراء في محميه الملك عبد العزيز
الملكيه وذلك بعد موجه الامطار الاخيره
التي شاهدتها البلاد اداره المحميه طول
الامطار بزراعه بعض الاشجار والبذور
المتوائمه مع طبيعه تضاريس
[موسيقى]
من هنا من محميه الملك عبد العزيز في
الرياض مراسل العربيه هاني
حياك الله
نستمتع معك بالاجواء وبالمناظر في المحميه
قناه العربيه نعم هناك طبعا اتساع واضح في
المسطحات الخضراء هنا في محميه الملك عبد
العزيز الملكيه والتي تبلغ مساحتها اكثر
من 28 الف متر مربع والواقع شمال مدينه
الرياض طبعا هذه الصور الخاصه التي
تلتقطها كاميرا عربيه بشكل مباشر سواء
الصور الجويه او كذلك الصور الارضيه
لاتساع المسطحات الخضراء وتساحه
الخضراء بعد العمليات
الزراعه التي قامت بي همم عملها الفتره
الماضيه محميه الملك عبد العزيز ضمن
مبادره السعوديه الخضراء وذلك بزراعه ما
همم ما يقارب همم المليون همم شجره طبعا
في الفتره الماضيه وكذلك سواء من انواع من
اشجار او كذلك من البذور طبعا حصيله محميه
الملك عبد العزيز او حصتها تحدي في
مساهمتها ضمن السعوديه الخضراء هي اكثر من
ثلاثه ملايين شجره وبذره سوف تحققها اا
خلال 20/25 ولكن من خلال ايضا بعد الامطار
الغزيره التي شهدتها مناطق عده في
السعوديه منها العاصمه الرياض هذه
المسطحات هي لنباتات بريه وكذلك بعض
الطيور التي كانت موجوده هنا وبعضها
المهاجره نلاحظها وان نرصدها عبر شاشه
العربيه في هذه النشره طبعا ايضا لن ننسى
ان الفتره الماضيه وايضا خلال الفتره
المقبله هي ما زالت تسعه ايضا محميه الملك
عبد العزيز الملكيه في تحقيقها للحفاظ على
الحيوانات البريه خاصه المهدده بالانقراض
طبعا لن انسى ايضا ان الفتره الماضيه
يتمكنت من اعاده توطين اكثر من 17 كائنا
فطريا همم انواعها
وكذلك الظبي والريم ذلك همم
عده طيور منها طائر القطا وطائر الحباره
وهي ما زال تسعه ايضا في رفع هذه او رفع
هذا العدد من عمليات التوطين للحيوانات
الفطريه اما بالنسبه لعمليه الاشجار
وتشجير اضافه الى الصور الجويه التي
نرصدها الان وان يلاحظ ايضا ليس فقط على
مسطح الاخضر همم المسطح الاخضر ولكن ايضا
هناك بقعه من البحيرات التي تكونت بعد
الامطار الغزيره والتي تشهدها تحديدا هذه
المنطقه التي نقف فيها ونردها وهي في روضه
نوره همم
المناطق ال- ال- ال-
التابعه لمحميه الملك عبد العزيز قامت
بزراعه الاثل وكذلك السجن
في الصور
طبعا نعم الامر هنا مسموح بعمليه التنزه
وايضا عمليه الكشته وهو المصطلح الدارج في
السعوديه وهي الطلعه البريه زي ما نقول و
اذا بنحولها اللهجه البيضاء هي الكشته
مجموعه من الشباب او مجموعه من الاصدقاء
وايضا من السياح اللي هم فتره الماضيه
كانوا يزورون لهذه الروضه وايضا الروضات
الاخرى التابعه للمحميه هي تبعد عن الرياض
لشمال الرياض تحديدا بقرابه الساعتين ونصف
الساعه طبعا هذه بتطلع لها خارج من الصبح
ومع قدر الضغط ومعاكتيس طال عمرك وتكون
محافظه
ايامك الحلوه واحلى ربيع طال عمرك حبيبي
والعزيمه على حسابك ههه
المفروض طبعا الاداره القناه هي اللي تقوم
بها الدوله لكن ما فيها كلام ههه الاجواء
حبيبي شكرا لك
واحلى ما في المتعه طال عمرك
تطلع
على الاخر
اداره البلديه والامن البيئي الموجودين
اللي هنا يرشدون للسياح والمتنزهين واصحاب
الكاشات على الحفاظ على هذه البيع نعم
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على التقديم لك همم
الماده شكرا
مراسل العربيه من المحميه الملك عبد
العزيز الرياض
شركه البحر الاحمر الدوليه عن بدي عمليه
تركيب الاولى الفلل العالم في منتجع جزيره
شيبارا ضمن مشروع البحر الاحمر الذي من
المقرر ان يفتتح ابوابه امام زوار العام
المقبل
[موسيقى]
خلال هذه الايام يدخل علينا ثاني نجوم
الشبط المسمى البلده مدته 13 يوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشتاء 90 يوما مقسمه على بدايه وشده
ونهايه فبدايته مع موسم صفري في شهر
سبتمبر وشدته مع موسم المربعانيه والشرطه
في شهر ديسمبر ويناير ونهايته مع موسم
الحميمين في شهر ابريل والعامه يقسمون 90
يوما من باب التقريب كالتالي 40 يوما
المربعانيه و50 يوما مقسمه على الشوبك
والعقارب فبرد اول اشتهى مضر على الاجساد
وبرد اخر شتاء نافع للاشجار توقوا البرد
في اوله وتلقاه في اخره فانه يعمل في
الاجساد كعمله في الاشياء فاوله محرق
واخره
مورق
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
و خلال هذه الايام يدخل علينا ثاني نجوم
الشبط المسماه عند العرب القدماء بالبلده
والعامه يسمونه شباط ثاني ومدته 13 يوما
وفيه تنتشر مواشي في طلبي ارزاقها لا تبكي
هم الرزقي فهو مقدر والعبد طوال حياتي
مرزوق واحفظ لسانك عن اذيه مسلم فسبابه
قال الرسول
فسوقوا
[موسيقى]
في الختام هذا تفكيره
صحيفه الامريكيه تكشف عن محادثات
16 من طرف ثالث
امر امريكي بقبول استقاله الحكومه
الكويتيه رئيسنا وزراء بعد اقل من اربعه
اشهر على تشكيلها
الرابعه تستعرض واقع النقل العام في شرق
السعوديه 130 الف راكب منذ اكتوبر الماضي
وبعد ما وجدت امطار غزيره محميه الملك عبد
العزيز ترتدي اللون الاخضر وجوله حصريه
للرابعه
تركب لنهائي او نصف نهائي السوبر السعودي
الهلال يواجه الفيحاء ورونالدو يقود النصر
امام الاتحاد
[موسيقى]